(plastic crackling)
- [Mark] Yo, put the water bottle down.
Okay.
Lawrence.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] So where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Charleston, South Carolina.
It's where I graduated high
school, went to college,
played football, all that fun stuff.
- [Mark] And you grew up
with both your parents?
- Yes, sir. Yeah, my mom...
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- It was pretty good for the most part.
I originally lived in
Columbia, South Carolina,
which is like 100 miles away,
and that's where I went to middle school,
and I shifted over to Charleston,
and it's when I first realized, you know,
like what a beach was for the most part
and man-made beaches as well.
It was very cool.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Your childhood was cool?
Everything was great? You
got along with both parents?
- Yes, sir. Yeah, yeah.
My dad worked a lot.
He would work late, late
shifts, so he never really
got a chance to go to most
of the football games,
but I mean he was there, he'd make it.
- [Mark] And what age were
you when you left home?
- Oh you know, I was what 17, turning 18.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So something like that.
- [Mark] Where'd you go?
- I moved into a friend's house.
He was, he had a full-time
job, his own vehicle,
and his own apartment.
And so I went from crashing at his pad
to paying him some cash
to live there, you know.
I'd give him like 200 bucks a month.
I didn't really know
like, the true meaning of,
you know, taking care of myself, you know.
So I didn't hold up then to my bargain
and it wasn't until we all
started hanging out together
and came together as like a
crew, we'd help each other out.
- [Mark] And so you got
to LA at what point?
- Man, I moved out of here fuckin' 2005,
six, seven, 2000, 2000 and what 10, yeah.
- [Mark] And are you living
out here on skid row right now?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] You're in a tent?
Yeah, I've been here
for fuckin' like seven,
six, seven years.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
Yes, sir.
- [Mark] What, what's your,
what's your drug out here?
- Man, I like a little bit of everything.
LA's notorious for their
crys, but I don't know,
the weed shops have, they have everything,
you know, from everywhere.
So that's a really good
choice. I don't know.
I don't really mess around
with any of the other stuff
around here. It's kind of bogus
or it's difficult to find.
- [Mark] So your main drug is what?
- Crys, yeah probably Crys.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Well, every, everybody does it.
It's, and nobody frowns upon it, so.
- [Mark] You still, are
you still in contact
with your family?
- From time to time.
Yeah, we've actually grown to spread apart
this last two years or so,
has been kind of extremely distant.
I've contacted them
only a handful of times.
I don't know. For some
reason, I don't know.
This, it's yeah.
These past two years have
been kind of distance.
- [Mark] But, do, do you
have any kids of your own?
- Yeah, yeah. I have a newborn.
- [Mark] You have one child?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where is he or she?
- She's, she's with her mom and
they, they live here in LA.
- [Mark] Do you see her?
Are you in her life?
- No, I'm not in contact with them.
- [Mark] No?
- Huh uh, we,
you know, I kinda like,
I've lost contact with them,
I guess, you know.
And I haven't, I haven't
talked to my family either
and I'm sure they don't
have anything to say, so.
I don't.
- [Mark] what are you doing for money now?
- I don't have any money right now.
I've, I just got all my
money stolen from me.
Somebody tapped into my EBT
card as soon as I got it
and took all my cash and my card.
And they said up at the
office I have to file
a claim, police report and
nine out of 10 times that they,
even if they do pursue, that
I'm only gonna get my cash.
And that's, you know, it's,
it's not, it's still not,
it's not fair.
- [Mark] Yeah. Bad stuff
happens here a lot.
- If they pursue and most
of the time they don't.
So, no, it's just, it's pretty sure...
- [Mark] But in general,
what do you do for money?
- It's extremely difficult
to get work around here.
Recycling, fortunate enough for me
I know the late night recyclers,
so that if I miss in the morning time,
that I can go at night and cash out
and still have money to
get something to eat.
But even that is extremely difficult
in competition with everybody else, like,
and then when you, when
you go to pick cans,
everybody, they nowadays we
leave the cans, the, the doors
to the trash cans open, so
that the next person can see.
- [Mark] Right.
- You know and you see
one trash can fucked up
and there goes your route for the night,
because he's one step ahead of you.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Just, yeah man, that shit happens, so.
Usually I would walk from
downtown to MacArthur Park
and between downtown and MacArthur Park
I would collect averagely
speaking $10 worth of cans.
And it's just enough.
It fills up everything.
One whole cart, maximum it's 10 bucks.
- [Mark] Yeah. How old are you?
- I'm 30. I'm about to be 31 in January.
- [Mark] Do you have any plans?
I had, I had plans.
Honestly, since, since everything happened
and it being extremely
difficult to find work,
I've been living life,
the maximum bum status.
Just, not that I don't give a fuck,
but I'm absolutely not wasting any effort
on anything until it's time.
And at that point, then
I'll take a step forward
in the right direction,
whatever direction that is.
- [Mark] Right.
- But until then, nah dud, like,
I'm not going on a crazy
mission, side missions,
gonna be a redirected, misinterpreted.
I'm just gonna sit back and chill.
(indistinct)
- [Mark] Well, Lawrence, thank
you so much for talking me.
- Yeah man, for sure.
- [Mark] Good luck with
everything out there.
- All right.
- [Mark] Be careful.
- Thank you, thank you. You do the same.